what was it about the bigger films that
you felt like you were missing
personally that you wanted to get back
to and be able to do with a movie like
this well I really came of age after
having written swingers and and been in
that and that's close to 20 years ago
and when I wrote that script it hit me
very quickly it hit me in a few weeks
and I never knew I was going to make it
and it was a it's where I started and I
was lucky enough through elf and through
iron man to work my way up and
fortunately be involved with the type of
movies that are still relevant having
been through that you see that there's a
whole there's a there there there's a
whole class of films that just aren't
being made anymore because the DVD
markets gone away for the most part and
so all those mid-range budget movies
that have won Academy Awards they're
about people those movies aren't being
green LED anymore and the big ones are
are the ones that are safe bets or safer
bets and a movie business is still you
know is trying to contend with changing
times and now we have a world market so
specific cultural films are not really
they're there they're harder to come by
but thanks to new media and the money
that's coming in through digital the low
end budget movies are starting to rise
up enough to be able to do a movie like
this and and I wanted to make a movie
for grown-ups I wanted to make a movie
about about fatherhood about balancing
career and family and all the things
that I would would have you know the
same the same part of my of my of my my
soul that I was able to put into
swingers when I was in my 20s I want to
make a movie in my 40s about all the
things that I've encountered as being a
dad and and being in a career that I've
been passionate about a career where you
have to balance art and commerce which
is a you know goes back to the Sistine
Chapel and beyond that's a it's a great
theme to play with and about finding
your you know finding your inspiration
and when you're when you're my age it's
it's rededicating yourself and focusing
yourself because a lot of little
decisions
every year that seemed innocuous put you
in a position where it's like whoa where
am i what am i doing what am I still
excited about what I'm doing I'm not
really like the guy here because I like
the big movies they're fun but I don't
want to do to just one kind of movie I
want to be able to do things like this
and and you know if you're willing to
take a pay cut and and call in some
favors and shoot it in the month you
could you could do it and so I wanted to
and this has been the best experience I
could ever remember having okay so
obviously you had to call in these
favors there's a couple Iron Man cast
members in there Dustin Hoffman I the
crowd got very excited when he showed up
on so I got excited too when he read the
script he liked it I didn't know him
before and he started talking about i
was expecting always you food eyz way he
started talking about Kramer vs Kramer
and I was I don't even think of that I
rewatched I was like oh my god it's it's
a divorce dad and back then movies could
be a little more ambiguous it's not like
you're a bad dad it's you just your dad
that's not really a good dad and you're
not really connected to your kid because
you're too busy with the day-to-day
stuff and and the way they argue and
reconnect actually through food also in
that film really inspired me and I and I
look back at the script and and and and
reworked some of the scenes well with a
much smaller budget compared to the
larger films what are some of the frills
or creature comforts that you found
yourself missing on this set the only
thing that I really missed was the
ability to pay people with what they
really deserve especially the below the
line people the actors they'll go off
and make other movies and and and and
they'll do well for themselves and but
the but the below the line people who
wanted to work in LA and I you know I I
fought very hard to keep it here we'd
unfortunately to get the rebate
hopefully that situation is changing the
next few years so that more people could
qualify
and I'll work hard to help that however
I could but it's amazing if you say hey
we're going to make a movie if you liked
the script you're going to I'll make a
movie you're proud of and you'll get to
go home sleep with your with your family
and and and you get the best cruise in
the world here and you you equipment
everything with the infrastructure is
here so when you tap into that you get
exponentially how much work you could
accomplish in any given day the you know
just that just the experience level and
the appreciation that people get to just
do what they when they came into the
business what was taken for granted but
everybody works for less than they would
normally because it's a lower budget
film so that's the only thing but I
don't mind shooting in a month I loved
it it was it like created a sense of
urgency you know I wrote it last January
and now year and a half later it's out
in theatres it's it's very exciting it's
fun and part of to me what's interesting
about about kitchen culture is that it's
like a pirate ship there are rough
characters from all countries all walks
of life but then they're like total food
nerds so it's like pirates putting on a
musical you know and to me that's like
so it's so rich with opportunity and I
try to capture that